[Music]
Pentatonix leading lady
Kirsten Maldonado is breaking now and
going solo with the release of her debut
single break a lip
[Music]
I feel like this entire thing is just
like a new confidence kick I've always
just tried to like really drive myself
and I feel like it's a struggle you know
everyone kind of hazzard insecurities
and like what's going on and I'm just
I'm so happy that I that I had such
amazing people to work with that really
helped me put this vision out this is
your first solo endeavor like did you
fill the nerves do you feel any pressure
breaking out on your own I did I feel
like I there's definitely a feeling of
wanting to or needing to succeed I feel
like for sure I never thought I would be
able to put something out like that's so
honest and so me right um because of its
curious or because of you know whatever
me only trapping myself I guess and so
just that it's out and that people are
receptive and and that the vision of
what has been happening is so great and
everyone captured it so well and so
beautifully is just like an honor so I'm
I'm elated you know obviously with this
solo project and when I'll be leaving
the group I think a lot of fans out
there are wondering what does the future
hold for pentatonix I know you're
focusing on this right now but you know
can you guys are broken up right no
we're not broken up um honestly we just
want the best for each other you know I
mean we've been a family for the past
six years and we're all just like taking
a new chapter as it comes you know as
life changes as life comes at us and
we're also support of each other and
just want the best for each other so
we're just excited for everything that's
going to come obviously you know obvious
irreplaceable and we're in a family and
so it's definitely going to be hard and
difficult and different but um but yeah
we're just so excited objects
you
[Music]